y hablamos ahora de revistas reprende
prensa repasamos todos los titulares de
la prensa internacional y ya está
conmigo lista en el estudio rosa pérez
más de un rosa buen jueves para ti buena
mañana aquí en la ciudad de bogotá con
mucho frío amanecimos audio y rosa pero
vamos a hablar entonces de la guerra no
que venimos a relatando la durante todas
estas semanas desde que empezó la
invasión el pasado 24 de febrero vamos a
ver como relata la prensa internacional
el ataque al teatro de mariupol primero
vamos con la repubblica de italia y
luego con el monstruo time buenos días
raúl exactamente no este último episodio
destacado en portadas alrededor
alrededor del mundo vemos precisamente
como este medio italiano de hecho lo
lleva en la portada en papel de este
jueves horror en el teatro de mariupol
por otro lado vemos el moscú times este
medio ruso también que en el texto
destaca recuerda lo que hemos señalado
que es que imágenes satelitales previas
al ataque muestran como al lado y lado
del edificio de este teatro estaba
escrito en él de ti niños niños
presentes refugiados en ese teatro donde
se estima que más de mil personas se
albergaban se protegían pues de los
bombardeos también cita la respuesta de
las autoridades ucranianas que han
calificado el ataque de crímenes de
guerra y el alcalde de mariupol ha
llegado a definirlo como genocidio
veamos ahora rosa otro punto de vista
como lo titulan los medios catalogados
como pro kremlin bien pues por un lado
rt reproduce el discurso del ministerio
de defensa ruso que asegura que el
ataque fue más bien una explosión
provocada por el grupo ucraniano neonazi
al soft que habría secuestrado a todos
los civiles y dentro de este teatro para
utilizarlos como escudo humano y pues
señala que según el ministerio de
defensa ruso nunca fue el teatro un
objetivo militar porque no quisieron
caer de nuevo en la provocación de este
grupo de extrema derecha asof después de
lo sucedido recordemos en el hospital
maternal también de mariupol que rusia
justificó ese ataque precisamente
diciendo que eso era una centro de
operaciones de este grupo
ultranacionalista de ucrania y por otro
lado el consomé los caía pravda pues se
señala que su corresponsal ya había sido
alertado de este ataque por parte del
comando soft y asegura que según las
informaciones que citan este artículo la
ciudad de mariupol ya va a estar
liberada es decir invadida por los rusos
para el fin de semana raúl y en estos
tiempos de incertidumbre en medio de una
guerra también es difícil de corroborar
a todas estas todas estas
contradicciones de parte y parte no rosa
pero precisamente de eso vamos a hablar
en el artículo the washington post
porque dice que occidente rompió el muro
de propaganda del kremlin que además
dice este artículo rosa este es un texto
a raúl de drew hardware y paulson que lo
que aseguran es que distintos
programadores informáticos junto con lo
que califica guerreros de la información
están consiguiendo perforar este muro
banda rusa como comentaba y señala
algunas de las estrategias que siguen
para hacer llegar al conjunto de la
población de rusia lo que realmente está
pasando en esta guerra brutal y que
muchos medios de comunicación rusos pues
no pueden mostrar entre otras
herramientas señala el hecho de usar
distintos números de teléfono y
direcciones de correo electrónico
hackeadas de grandes bases de datos
rusos para hacer llegar a gran escala
pues lo que decíamos el número de
fallecidos reales en esta guerra o
imágenes no de ataques rusos pues en
ucrania ahí lo tiene atrás de usted del
medio medusa y hablemos precisamente de
esa propaganda que dicen no la popular
letra zeta que identifica a las tropas
rusas rosa quien más hay sobre esto pues
como dice este medio sigue indagando en
el origen y la razón de la difusión de
concretamente está zeta dice que
básicamente la administración federal de
rusia está instando a las
administraciones regionales a usarla un
poco como quieran y como puedan y que
pues cada uno está haciendo
se le ocurre flashmob en escuelas y
cosas así y buscando el origen un poco
de este símbolo para utilizarlo como
apoyo a las tropas rusas señala este
medio que podría estar vinculado al
departamento de marketing de la cadena
precisamente rt algo que la directora de
rte ya margarita simonián han negado
pero lo que es cierto es que en rt en la
página web uno pueden entrar dentro de
la pestaña soft tienda y comprar
camisetas con la letra zeta por unos 12
dólares estadounidenses por otro lado
también cita fuentes de la presidencia
que señalan que es un símbolo venga de
quien venga horrible porque no se
entiende que parece publicidad para
selenski y que además es raro porque no
es un símbolo del alfabeto cirílico
cuando la operación se supone que va de
salvar el mundo ruso y también a raúl y
hay muchas fuentes anónimas en este
texto de hecho mucha gente que dice que
prefiere guardar el anonimato por miedo
a represalias pero hay quien cita
también un hombre de negocios vinculados
al grupo wagner este grupo de
mercenarios también como posibilidad de
persona al origen pues de este símbolo y
también se pueden comprar entonces todo
este merchandising también como lo
estaba comentando rosa pues hablemos
ahora de la situación en mali con
nuestras cadenas hablamos de france 24 y
radio france francia internacional rosa
que es lo que está pasando en este
momento con en nuestros medios de
información porque el gobierno maliense
ha decidido digamos de alguna manera
vetar la información que nosotros damos
en ese territorio es un poco de contexto
también a nuestra audiencia rosa bien
raúl pues esto se enmarca dentro de este
giro no por en mali y en otros países
africanos también contra francia contra
la que era pues su potencia colonizadora
de hecho esta información la ha conocido
france24 i
efe a través de un comunicado que la
junta militar de malí ha hecho llegar a
la agencia afp francesa también qué e
informa de que hasta nueva orden la
difusión de rf y de france 24 en mali
queda suspendida esto en razón de unas
supuestas falsas alegaciones contra las
fuerzas armadas malienses y es que
informaciones de erc del 14 y 15 de
marzo dan la palabra a víctimas de
abusos presuntamente cometidos por el
ejército de mali y el grupo wagner de
este grupo de mercenarios rusos como
comunicadas de hecho la junta de malí
llega a comparar pues estos canales con
radio mil colin que es una arma que se
utilizó por el gobierno y tú en el
genocidio contra los tutsis en ruanda y
rápidamente comenta raúl que el grupo
france media monde el grupo al que
pertenece air france 24 ya ha comentado
que lamenta esta decisión y rechaza con
vehemencia las acusaciones infundadas
que cuestionan gravemente el
profesionalismo de sus antenas rosa
gracias por todas las por toda esta
información de revista de prensa nos
vemos mañana con más y pasamos a saludar
a nuestra primera invitada al día